Samuel Leeds is one of Britain's most
successful property entrepreneurs a
high-flying investor a best-selling
author and founder of a leading property
education company Samuel is recognized
as one of the brightest young stars in
British business following his meteoric
rise to success by becoming a
multi-millionaire in his twenties
Samuel is in the elite a salons at UK
property investors over the next five
weeks thirteen burning property
entrepreneurs will be battling it out to
prove that they are the ultimate
property investor the prize 20,000
pounds of Samuels cold hard cash to
kick-start one candidates property
journey this is the
I know my stuff I started property with
no money 20 care to me would give me
really good pick start into my property
journey I want to win and I'll do
anything I mean I'll do my best at the
moment I don't have any properties so
I'm in the very beginning stages of my
property journey
I actually just finalized on I deal with
my mum on Friday I've got a serviced
accommodation unit and purchasing the
property up north for a refurb a very
cheap one I may add I can think of all
options and all avenues my biggest
strength is confidence 20,000 doesn't
seem like a lot of money but it is I am
a bit of a perfectionist if I'm gonna
make something happen
I'll go out and get it so I start
investing property roughly around
September last year I'm very motivated I
think I should win 20,000 pounds because
it will really help me excel my property
journey I think I just returned with
20,000 films my name's Abby Patterson
I'm from York and a property investor
[Music]
good morning and welcome to the eviction
over the next four weeks you'll be
partaking in several property investment
challenges where one of you will be
winning a 20,000 pound prize to invest
in property yourself my trusted business
aids Russell and Alastair will be
following you everywhere you go and
helping me decide who will win this
life-changing prize your first challenge
will be this morning where you will
visit a property that I have secured
your job is to go to the property assess
the property and package it up ready to
sell it tomorrow you'll need to assess
the market value you'll need to assess
the rental demand the condition does the
property need work if so how much work
and then tomorrow I'm going to be having
a party here at the castle where 20 of
my high net worth individual friends
will be visiting and you will have an
opportunity to present and sell your
property deals to the investors the
winning team will be the team who can
present their property the most
accurately authentically and ultimately
who can make the sale and get the
highest fee for this challenge I'm going
to split you into two teams so we have
two properties this is in East
stoke-on-trent and this property with
the address on the keys is in north
stoke-on-trent so please can I have you
in two teams the boys to my right and
the girls to my left go
now you're in two teams please select
yourself a team leader within your group
okay thank you so who is team leader of
the boys please thank you and who is
team leader of the girls thank you so
boys you wanted to get your keys the
house keys from Alastair and Alice Dale
will be following you down and joining
you in the property girls you will be
joined with Russell so you can get the
house keys from Russell and he will be
going with you and watching you I'll be
seeing you tomorrow at the party in the
meantime good luck
the girls arrived at their property to
see what they have to work with and how
best they can package it to sell to
their investors if the numbers work and
there's a probability of a decent return
the team can sell the deal for a hefty
finder's fee big bathroom the team bump
into one of the current tenants who
tells them what he's looking for in a
student accommodation kitchen space
because I food so I kicked him with a
tiny preparation area she was using
magic plan to create a floor plan it's
like measuring but it does it on an app
and it draws it for you me and daddy
I've spoken to some builders today
already trying to get some quotes and
see what they can do yeah I guess it's
quite clear that Hannah is taking very
much control of this of this Tash has
got a really good idea of what to look
for in the rooms to notice the damaged
notes the cracks there's been a lot of
the others were completely missing now
we know what the girls think let's find
out what work actually needs doing to
bring this house up to scratch
so I mean first off there's a lot of
boxing that needs to be done that all
these pipes look at this that need to be
boxed in there's no carpet or anything
here so it
first impressions is really important
all this wallpaper needs to come off and
it must be painted kitchen again the
kitchen is not too bad and it looks ok
when you first walk in first impressions
but it's just the little details things
like this damp up in the corner that
needs to be sorted out of course there
needs to be lampshades some of the
windows again I've got a lot of dirt and
damp and mold around them which just
needs to be cleaned out upstairs is
where things get a little bit more
severe again at first glance it can look
not too bad but there's cracks look at
this there's cracks in the ceilings all
down the walls the windows are steamed
up they're moldy this this definitely
needs more than a lick of paint this
needs some serious attention some
serious thought and to get it done to a
high standard is you need to get a
several thousand pounds spinning on it
carpets again you could try and clean
them but even if you clean these carpets
they don't match and they are absolutely
filthy I always went out my HMOs fully
furnished and I'm sorry but this I don't
even know if you can call this furniture
right what is this meanwhile back at the
castle the girls are conjuring up a plan
to sell the deal to Samuels investors at
the pitch later on right so shall we
just have a catch-up see what we're all
start thinking with this property then
do you know how much this was bought for
I was really impressed with the team
tonight in particular Alisha because she
managed to arrange a builder to come in
he gave very realistic advice so that's
gonna be key when they're selling the
deals tomorrow the fact they've had a
builder come in and give them this
advice is gonna go down gonna go down
very well on the other side of Stoke the
boys take a look around their property
to evaluate exactly what they have to
sell to their investors
look we can reach the really change
changin so think there's a bit of a bit
of dump on that wall over there that one
needs someone out the the bar from needs
some ceilings done and the floor injury
dunno the boiler looks fine to be fair
the boy does look fine leads out of
confuse box yeah see what that looks
like
I think it just needs needs a good in
it's a good clean and just a bit of
paint and a bit of a makeover but
there's not I mean there's a few cracks
in the walls but they don't seem like
they're a big problem it's still livable
so it just needs a bit of a makeover a
bit of pain and just highly enough a bit
really so when you're looking at
property you should really move suppose
arena just I'm just moving this now look
what a phone like none of them have
sported any of this sort of damage and
and it just comes from not moving stuff
so whenever you're in a property looking
you should always be moving things are
associated and near the wall it hates
all sorts of stuff thanks for the advice
Alastair yeah it's a it's a decent sized
garden the fence needs doing what we
need to work out because that that me
offense has come down there I don't know
if it's from the weather or something
but we need to kind of work out who's
we'll find out whose responsibility is
to put that fence back up and Stephen
here removing some of the link from his
measure with real finesse and flair
maybe I think I think this is probably
not rich rich is going to be the one
that this he's not enjoying this task
that much I think it's gonna quit
challenging for Ricky his strengths are
elsewhere I thinking instead of pricing
up sort of work and things that are in
this here some properties and but who
knows I may be wrong and I hope I am but
maybe but I think James will Excel
because this is this what it does day
today
I think Elliot will do very well so yeah
there's just wait and see who knows it's
basically just trying to get a good feel
for the property room sizes any major
issues I've done what he's changing
you're gonna be if it's gonna be ten key
investment hezonia money new spending so
this house is a very big house it's got
four tenants in at the moment it's a
multi let and we've got it for a hundred
thousand pounds so let's have a look
around and see what worked means doing
to the property definitely needs a new
carpet definitely needs a paint kitchen
you could maybe get away with just
cleaning it but if it was my kitchen I
would be getting a new kitchen for this
property now what the boys probably
didn't notice is that in the shed
there's a brand new kitchen ready to be
fitted but I'm not going to tell them
that I'll see if they notice that but
really it definitely needs a new kitchen
double glazed so just worktops really
and it would make it look a whole lot
better
the carpets are clearly very very very
cheap carpets they're filthy and they
just need changing I think with a paint
decoration carpets they'll make the
place look a lot better interesting
again that this place is being rented
out as a four-bed HMO but there's no
fire doors on the property it's not
really very good I think probably you're
talking 10,000 pounds again similar to
the last property 10,000 pounds should
be able to be enough to give this
property a very good uplift fire doors
furniture somewhere between 10 and
15,000 pound and this will be very very
high standard and your rents should
easily be sixteen seventeen hundred
pound a month and with good tenants the
boys have agreed that the refurb cost
for their house will be five and a half
thousand pounds which is nearly half the
price recommended by Samuel let's listen
to project manager James try and justify
the miscalculation while we enjoy 30
seconds of looking at Elliott's bush
beard
so 1,500 is what the current growth is
going in gross and they students or
professional students okay so I think
the seriously I don't even care about
the property just look at that cost us
to do the work what our n rents are
gonna be just go get our figures on it
and if you look in within a quarter of a
mile the last
two years you've got a range from like
80k that's like 300k at this rate I
believe the boys are going to lose this
task if they do I believe James needs to
go he took the lead and he is the one
has underestimated the refurb caused by
half failing that I think Stephen should
go Stephen has contributed nothing to
this task and I feel he needs to go as
well Samuel has invited 20 of his
property mates to the castle to watch
the team's pitch their deals in the
hopes of finding an investor up first
the boys who here knows that their money
is shrinking in the bank thank you today
we're going to tell you with undeniable
proof how you can achieve minimum of 25
percent return on investment elio what
are you doing what this is really
awkward now I'm going to pass you over
to John in a second
who is physical coordination and by the
looks of it is color coordination is
it's not the best there are toilets he's
going to dazzle you with the deal and
everything is gonna be a-okay thanks I
think all right my name is John Raible
I'm gonna be going through the actual
deal with you so it's a four-bedroom
home Oh in stoke-on-trent currently
we've got it for a hundred thousand
pounds it's in a prime student location
and we've secured it 20 percent below
market value with that you'd be looking
at return on investment of 25 percent
who here thinks that 25 percent is a
good deal within property I think that's
a cracking deal John thank you it's all
right now with creative strategies or
know many of your hungry investors with
this deal if you use bridging and then
did the refurb or if you did buy reefer
be finance or these kind of strategies
you will be able to achieve a greater
return than this
we've looked at into this and we've
looked at what kind of ROI you would get
with that and we know you'll be able to
achieve at least doesn't look convinced
so we'll include a change of windows a
couple of the audience giggling there
[Music]
Rick I just like a bit more of a
breakdown on the money going in and the
money back cuz we're talking about
percentages which actually sound pretty
good on the face of it but I just like
to know how much money is needed in and
what is the true breakdown of that kinda
like a little bit a fairly big picture
but a little bit line by line yeah no
fantastic question completely understand
you want to see a full breakdown of it
now there are different options
obviously as invested in a different
options way that we can finance this
deal so depending on the way that you're
going to finance it and what lenders you
use that will really it will differ with
the numbers slightly good work Ricky
completely avoiding answering the
question there and if I buy it for cash
I do the work and then refine those I
get that if we just look so we can all
compare let's say the traditional way so
let's say I buy it and get a mortgage
just let's just run the numbers on that
so that you know we've got a benchmark
yeah now of course I said we're limited
with time now what were he just answer
the question laughter well I'm not I
mean I don't know if I want to come and
see you afterwards dependent on the
answer here because if this is a waste
of my time I won't be sticking around so
he's a 100k purchase how much money's
name I completely understand what you're
saying
obviously we we want to deal with
serious investors like you
well I think I'll qualify myself while
doing in this room and this is the
fourth time I'm asking how much money is
going needed to go in is a 100k 100k
purchase price how much money is needed
yeah again I would say depending on how
you're going to finance it traditional
mortgage you're gonna say if your new
traditional mortgage it then there will
be a slight delay for when you can
refine it I don't need to reflect
someone so I can traditional Morgan I'm
not worried about the refiners I'm after
the comparison I'm buying it 400k my
mortgage what's the deposit that's
required yeah what's the deposit that's
required as if there's other people in
the room that are oh this is an absolute
car crash I've got a question
the Armen investor is a pretty simple
question yeah how much deposit on a
hundred thousand pound house I I
personally wouldn't be able to do
business with you yeah if I cannot get a
straight answer to a straight question
yeah no I need to interject with that
straight yeah and I feel so passionately
in a room with people and I'm asking a
question as an investor I expect to get
an answer of was it just seems like you
don't know after that dog's dinner of a
performance from the boys it's the girls
turn to try and pitch their deal to the
investors how many of you here today
would be interested in buying a property
if the return on investment was around
20% anyone okay we're not off to a good
start
never mind we'll move on the profit for
the first 12 months would be 6,000 the
ROI would be nineteen point five percent
and the investment total investment in
would be 36 okay this property as we
seen right now is already rented and now
it has three great bedrooms I mean each
of the bedrooms we talk in double
bedrooms and there is one that will take
a king-sized wait but the best feature
in the property is actually deter the
the bathroom the bathroom would easily
be converted to another bedroom of
course
nc because who needs a bathroom these
days it's who the property had a little
look around and he actually gave us a
figure four thousand pound
that's anything between a shower to the
kitchen all the painting and decorating
even the furnitures included in that and
that's actually included in the figures
that we previously showed so in the
current condition you can get 325 pounds
per room which is not that great but we
have done our research and we know that
there are a couple of properties on the
same street that can achieve up to 425
pounds per room so the mass spec company
who were working for just as an example
they just took on a property last week
that had six bedrooms this week four of
them are already let how would you like
to have a property where four of your
rooms are let in one week yeah it goes
can I ask a quick question about the
percentages that you came up with one
was 19.5% one was 17.6% nor 17.8% 17%
okay can you tell me what that equates
between actual rent figures so but I can
quickly workout off the top of my head
because you're recommending that we
spend four thousand pounds on this to do
a refurb how long would it take me to
recuperate that four thousand pounds
extra refurb when there's only a what a
couple of percent difference in the ROI
on this so the rent the profit that you
can get per year is six thousand nine
hundred and twenty can we just
recalculate the initial yeah I mean I
would be I became to do that so it's it
sounds eleven eleven thousand five
hundred and then you're saying the other
option is for home so every two years
every two years so that's it's very
refurb dependent really isn't it only
bringing a refurb in a four thousand
pounds how does a three bed HMO going to
work no I
what's the bills bills one thirty and a
hundred and thirty per months yeah it's
just not realistic have you ever run a
HMO before any of you do you have you
any idea how hot the tenants have it I
mean he's not realistic that figure it's
just not realistic after some pretty
atrocious pitches both the boys and the
girls have an opportunity to network
with the
Esther's to try and sell that deals
face-to-face I have a question I'm going
for the guy who looks like The Milk Tray
man I'm gonna go straight to you I would
have said you being what you said and
how you presented yourself today so this
is one decision maker and this would be
well that's holy miss caught that one
it's probably why all these guys are
millionaires and I'm just saying a dark
room talking into a microphone
meanwhile John shows us how to truly
engage in a sales conversation Blues are
achieving full 57 I'm an old some of the
investors not happy at all with the
girls as they seem to have ignored some
of them completely it's really ignored
let's do a bit here alone I spent all
day I left the office I'm not attending
the office it may have real
responsibilities yeah I know honest
actually Trevor is Collard Rickey to
negotiate some numbers on the boys house
but can Rickey hold his nerve apart from
a finder's fee I mean 14 sold another
one
yeah the altie mr. twelve months ago 160
I've got it all here I made copies so
I've got you on a road team okay okay
okay I'm with it okay okay we're World
War one 25 1 - it's fine it's gonna
refinance at one to five okay so in
refinance is at one to five so you're
gonna be able to pull out your hundred
and six okay that they put in and is 19
K left in there it's nineteen thousand
equity equity it's not live another day
the ninety thousand is not me left in
there that's equity left him that up
equity in the house how much was the
refurb the refurb their guide who's
doing the hit small manager he quoted us
four to five thousand pounds oh this
could spell trouble
Elliott's trying to pitch to Marcus but
he doesn't realize that he's not
actually the decision-maker the one day
of scaffolding to just sort out that
little bit of roof so you guys going to
be involved with that is there any way
of driving down that price just a little
time well what's the minimum you think
you can do that the minimum is the for
compensation if if we add value the
finest we you know we've got to find
mean you could get in and do some
painting make sure it comes in at four
thousand I don't know why the boys are
laughing if someone wants to pay me for
grants of paint their house I'll be
round in a shot if that's what if we
could reduce the costs by being part of
that process is that something that
would promote you to buy the deal it
would certainly get me thinking about it
for sure
surely at this point Marcus should step
forward and admit that he's not the
decision maker
Thanks I don't have a lot of confidence
yeah you go away and do that next one
you'll learn here maybe we can talk
about okay if we you know if we done a
deal today shook hands today set in
stone do you know what I would but you
haven't shown me spreadsheet yeah I
appreciate that okay
subject to me like in that 1500 rookies
hand down come on shake it seemed first
you have about you have three and a half
minutes to go and your team yeah okay
well you loser do thanks for your time
I'll be back in less than three and a
half minutes there you go thanks thanks
you know if you're happy with the the
sourcing fee and you're happy with the
property
what would it take if you don't mind me
asking for you to feel comfortable
checking on it now he doesn't actually
make the decisions okay
so it's more the principle of what it
represents yeah but we have a deal in
principle yes they got a deal for full
prices with the wrong person but a deal
is still a deal thank you no she okay
that's well awkward but Ricky's also got
a deal with Trevor
that is fantastic two deals sold for the
boys good job lads it's a hundred
thousand pounds reduce the repo we've
taken the reef
1,500 shakin hands on it subject to
pictures I literally feel that that guy
could sell ice to Eskimos so to recap
the girls didn't sell their deal to
anyone despite there being an
eye-watering amount of money in that
room the boys got two deals Ricky got
completely outfoxed by Trevor and sold
his deal for a 1500 pound sourcing fee
which is down from almost four thousand
quid and the promise of a 2,000 pound
refurb which is nearly three and a half
grand less that the original estimate
naughty boy Ricky Elliott got had
checked for the full three thousand nine
hundred fifty pounds saucing feet on the
promise of a 4,000 pound reverb which is
a cracking deal but he sold it to the
wrong person
let's join Samuel getting some feedback
from the investors over to you I was
interested in it and he just assumed
Ricky we assumed that we were all
together I was quite happy to negotiate
separately as well but he he didn't take
the time to actually think about who
he's he's doing deal with I thought the
girls presentation was better than the
boys I thought they held their own a lot
better when we pressed them yes so just
an observation on the deals really when
I've been through the numbers at first
you were thinking all actually maybe the
girls have not got as good a deal but
once you've really drilled through it
they actually ended up being about the
same return on investment based on the
numbers that we've got so actually off
you know that I think I'll word out but
probably all around about 18 percent
return on cash you know give or take
there's not that much difference there
but I think the really big thing with
the boys and they didn't use it as a
selling point was it's you have 20%
below market value and actually that
would able enable you to refine that's
all of your money out pretty much
straightaway the girls didn't close
the deal you know they're kind of
weren't really hungry for it I think if
they pushed us more we probably would
have we would have kind of maybe agreed
on on a fee for the deal
I didn't think Elliot was the strongest
in the presentation but one-to-one
outside he was fantastic and he really
did a great job as selling the deal to
me another one I think that's worthy of
a mention standing next to him Steven I
can't remember anything from Steven
negotiations complete investors feedback
received but will the deal stack in the
boardroom
okay so here's the verdict there's going
to be a winning team there's gonna be a
losing team the losing team three of you
will be evicted tonight and we have to
leave the castling at home so it's been
quite difficult working out who the
winning team is if I'm honest because
both teams had some serious serious
flaws boys the investors thought you
were a bit of a laughingstock you were
cocky and I don't know what Elliot
stance was about but it made the
investors not want to mingle with you
later on in the party at all it's like
you were trying to lose the challenge so
feel pretty let down the deal was good
but the the delivery was not good at all
Gill's well I'm going to be investing my
own money 20,000 pound with somebody and
my problem with you girls is not one of
you can sell the investors thought your
presentation was okay but you just you
just could not sell at all and some of
the investors said they were waiting for
you to come and speak with them and you
just didn't they wanted you to try and
sell to them at least with the boys
they had a fire and they were making an
effort to sell I don't know what you
were thinking and frankly the
competition was about who can sell the
deal and you couldn't sell so can't say
I'm happy with the girls can't seem to
up with the boys either but at the end
of the day you had a challenge and the
challenge was to sell a property so I'm
gonna give you the lowdown of what sold
if anything's sold and then we can work
out who the winning team is so boys you
kind of sold a deal to Marcus and
madruga and Marcus wanted to buy the
deal and in principle was happy to pay
you four thousand pounds your full fee
but the problem is his wife from a'dreea
is ultimately the decision maker and you
completely ignored madruga
and made her feel like rubbish so
despite her being the decision maker
after you
left Marcus has pulled out because mood
Rika felt like she was ignored
so Marcus did not go ahead with that
deal so there was no deal back however
you did speak to Trevor and I don't know
what was going on with the figures
exactly but he made you an offer of
fifteen hundred pounds on the basis that
the refurb could be done to a high
standard for two thousand pounds which
ricky said that could be done so on that
basis trevor has said that you can go
ahead so you did sell a deal for a grand
total of fifteen hundred pounds
girls you just couldn't sell he deal was
good it was equally as good as the boys
but you just couldn't sell and that's
your problem and mash you down for
however the investors warmed to the
girls a lot more than the boys and
despite you not being able to sell we
spoke to the investors afterwards and
there was an offer made for one of your
deals for a fee of three thousand pounds
so the girls are the winning team
so girls you'll be celebrating tonight
we've got a cocktail class for you boys
I'm going to give you a few minutes to
decide who's responsible for this
ultimately James has been the team
leader you did son a day out you thought
it for fifteen hundred pound someone's
responsible we're going to figure out
who that is and three of you will be
evicted tonight so I'm gonna give you a
few minutes to chat amongst yourselves
obviously we were talking in a group but
the conversation was with Marcus and
Mark and I said hello to her when I
walked over and there was no speaking
but at any point were you ever aware
that it was her that was making the
decision redundant no I know what no one
spoke I told us that at any point and we
were under the impression that we were
dealing with mark and Marcus and we was
had a deal in principle he shook on it
and and that was that this isn't like
anybody said who just didn't like I mean
you might know what she was might put
bad taste on everyone I thought I says
I'm not saying that specific people
specific but I'm saying if they didn't
like someone they might have thought
that whole group okay so three of you
guys are gonna be evicted tonight James
you were team leader yeah so who's
responsible for this I think we had sold
it it had been closed and because we
hadn't addressed all that all the people
that were it sold to her what we'd sold
it to Marcus but then Marcus his wife is
the decision-maker
yes who said that you were rude to her
yes what did you contribute to this
Steve because no one remembered your
name I did my due diligence and I came
across I thought I did it quite
confidently and yeah I didn't have any
problem speaking to anyone after and why
did why did everybody all the investors
cite that they felt that you'd
contributed the least that's their
opinion why it's their opinion is is it
valid and I don't feel this why is he
not valid I did my bit as much as
everyone else what did you do I've done
my I did the do due diligence part of
the time just keep saying this what
that's what I did
so extend here I did that so I'm going
to go for the whole picture you know I
wanted to tell me what due diligence she
did that was so important that resorted
into you in this situation due diligence
wasn't the failing point was it so what
did you contribute my part in the
presentation and when we were out the
property I did to be measuring up as
well we had all different jobs to do and
I did my bit Ricky you said that you
thought that the refurb could be done to
a very high standard for a 2,000 pound
budget the only reason that you might
stir salad area at all was because you
said that is that true what were you
lying just to sell the deal I don't I
think is it true or is it not true
the full reverb wouldn't be done it
doesn't matter it wouldn't be but you
thought you said that it would be and
that was the basis of
in the deal so why did you lie to Trevor
I think I didn't lie straight to Trevor
so what would you be able to do for two
thousand pounds in that property we
could do the the painting can be done
the bathroom can be sealed up and
cleaned up and give me a basic makeover
John you've been very quiet I think I
think John has I mean have you done I
think I did quite welcome presentation I
was quite nervous going on but I think I
performed quite well in there and the
networking I didn't obviously microcell
a deal there but I wasn't trying Network
you were the only person and that the
investor said that my trusted which is a
good sign Steve I don't think you've
contributed much you keep talking to me
about due diligence you weren't involved
in any of the conversations from what
I've picked up on the sale so it's a
tough one
but I think I think the first person
that I'm gonna evict is Steve with
regret you were evicted off you go
so I've got two more people to evict
although that this is just the nature of
it Ricky you're messed up
you sold a deal on the basis that you
can do a reefer for 2,000 pounds James
has backed you up and said that he
thinks that's possible with free labor I
don't think it's possible at all James I
think it's got massive potential I don't
think he's full of crap but at the end
of the day we didn't get the deal I
think John has done well John had good
feedback I think Johnny's safe John if
you want to go back to the house we got
there I got the hottest lead and I made
for what I know we sold that deal at a
full great sourcing fee for that deal
and the day there are three people in
that conversation where three people
stood there even if I didn't think she
was a person making a deal I would have
said John you didn't sell the deal but
you had people like Paul and Anne who
actually wanted the deal and had come to
buy something who said they're
interested and he said I'll be back in
five minutes but all three of you was
swarmed around markers for 20 minutes
just us two and I didn't I was speaking
to an individually and
and again we were following the heist
I'm Ricky was constantly messing up with
numbers he was like you're a laughing
stock in the in the presentation all
right I've heard enough
I think two more people have to go and
to me
bottom line is you messed up but I think
you've got potential and I think you'd
be ashamed to let you go this early so
Anthony you're safe go back to the house
Ricky you were a laughingstock you
messed up your numbers were all wrong
you messed your words up you turn the
presentation into a joke but ultimately
if it wasn't for you you wouldn't have
thought to deal at all so the fact that
you able to sell the deal to Trevor I
think it'd be a shame to evict you at
this stage so please go back to the
house it's a tough one I know I said
we're going to let three people go I
wouldn't like to see both of you go so
what I'm going to say is I'm going to
just choose one of you to be evicted at
this stage so who should it be he didn't
read the room right when he was when he
was pitching it did the dancing that's
declared and go down very well and then
although he did get the handshake it
wasn't with the person who was making
the deal and he alienated somebody who
was clearly a massively key factor in
that I think you've done a great job of
being team leader on this group and held
us together James I do think that I
think that your son fair for you to say
that I daily innate someone in the
conversation when you weren't there
simple as that I did not alien it I was
focused on the task at hand of getting
the deal sold and I only said that we
were under the impression that he was
negotiating the deal therefore the deal
was for him and no indication was more
used I don't know why should I stay
because I am eager I learn I come with
energy and although I agree as well
I read the room wrong and I'm I'm a fast
learner and I've do what it takes to be
successful and I ultimately I got a
handshake you got the deal but he didn't
exist cuz you're talking to the wrong
person and the decision-maker who had
the money and was the property person
felt ignored felt that you were rude to
her thought that the team was
to her ultimately you failed the
challenge one of you has to go I do
think that the fact that the girls sold
the deal to Madrid yeah and you were
standing next to me Rica and didn't
manage to sell the deal
James your team leader you were called
our again but Elliott I think you're
going to do very very well in business
and in life and it's with deep regret
that you are addicted James got massive
potential you need to step your game up
you need to have more humility and at 14
in this boardroom off you go it was very
tight between the boys
I think seemed that two people when it
could have been any any two and
disappointed it was me but this one is
I'm I was quite happy with what everyone
didn't escape with I get you know it's
up to the other people in the room and
obviously some younger team
[Music]
[Applause]
next time on the eviction we regret
you're the kid
[Music]
you